präsidentin der geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen dann bis heute mehrfach schon
betont ich will es aber noch mal einer
sagen wir leben in wirklich schwierigen
zeiten in zeiten in denen sich mehrere
krisen überlappen und sich gegenseitig
verstärken und ausgelöst durch den
russischen angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine in klimawandel und die
fortwährende corona pandemie und ihre
folgen wirklich große probleme in der
welt bereiten es sind zeiten in denen
immer klarer wird dass was anderswo in
der welt geschieht das betrifft uns auch
hier in deutschland unsere sicherheit
unsere zukunft unsere lebensqualität und
die menschen in deutschland erleben dass
dinge des alltäglichen lebens
treuer werden sie sehen die vielen
frauen und kinder die aus der ukraine
flüchten mussten die hier ankommen und
schutz suchen sie spüren den klimawandel
der immer neue rekorde erreicht bei den
witzen und sie sie bangen welche folgen
der gas mangel hat welche folgen
vergiftete flüsse raum können mehr denn
je erleben die menschen in deutschland
unmittelbar in ihrem alltag wie viele
einschränkungen wie viel leid wie viel
unsicherheit und gefahren mit solchen
krisen einhergehen und wie viel sie uns
abverlangen wie viel sie belasten wie
viel sie kosten als gesellschaft aber
eben auch ganz konkret jeden und jeder
einzelne von uns und jeder defizite
sozialdemokrat in jeder sozialdemokrat
erlebt was das für die menschen bedeutet
wie hart das ist es ist verführerisch
sich in so einer schwierigen zeit auf
die eigenen probleme und das direkte
umfeld zu konzentrieren aber genau das
wäre jetzt
absolut fatal denn die herausforderungen
vor denen deutschland steht die lassen
sich nicht durch einen kopf in den sand
stecken lösen und sie lassen sich eben
auch nicht rein militärisch lösen die
zeitenwende erfordert mehr den je
strategischen weitblick globale
solidarität und enge zusammenarbeit von
deutschland mit internationalen partnern
denn nur gemeinsam mit ihnen kann die
bundesregierung globale krisen
entschärfen und ihre komplexen ursachen
angehen und eben alles dafür tun dass
nicht ständig neue krisen entstehen es
ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen auch
deutschland und europa profitieren davon
wenn sich die sicherheitslage und der
lebensstandard in entwicklungsländern
verbessert und entwicklungspolitik ist
daher auch ein unabdingbarer teil einer
umfassenden einer vorausschauenden und
wirksame sicherheitsstrategie für
deutschland
am kollegin den kollegen dafür braucht
deutschland auch eine starke
entwicklungspolitik armut hunger und
fehlende chancen sind ein idealer
nährboden für unzufriedenheit für
konflikte und für kriege und die
deutsche entwicklungszusammenarbeit
setzt daher an der wurzel an mich bei
der globalen ungerechtigkeit gerade
jetzt gilt es den schwächsten zu helfen
gerade jetzt gilt das niemanden
zurückzulassen
es ist nicht egal wie ist den menschen
anderswo geht
[Applaus]
die herausforderungen nehmen massiv zu
und sie alle wissen hier wie schwer das
ist das mit einem schrumpfenden haushalt
zusammen zu bringen und deshalb hat die
bundesregierung im einzelplan 60 eine
krisenvorsorge vorgesehen und krisen
wirksam vorzubeugen und die folgen des
russischen angriffskrieges abfedern zu
können und ich sage ihnen wir brauchen
diese vorsorge für die
entwicklungspolitik auch und ich setze
hier auf ihre unterstützung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer stellen sich
der russischen invasion entgegen und sie
verteidigen ihre freiheit und
unabhängigkeit und die bundesregierung
wird ihnen wie olaf scholz ja noch mal
unterstrichen hat du so lange wie es
nötig ist an der seite stehen und dazu
unterstützt mein ministerium weiterhin
unsere ukrainischen partner es geht auch
jetzt schon darum geflüchteten menschen
ein dach über dem kopf heizung wasser
und strom zu geben und es geht darum
kindern eine schulbildung zu ermöglichen
oder familien bei der trauerbewältigung
zu begleiten und natürlich gehört auch
der wiederaufbau der ukraine schon dazu
das wird ich glaube dass es uns allen
bewusst eine immense aufgabe sein
akute not gibt es an vielen orten der
welt und der russische angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine hat unter anderem zur
verheerenden
preissteigerungen und globalen
lieferengpässen oder nahrungsmitteln
geführt hunger hunger ist wirklich
grausam ihnen wie putin als gegen
unschuldige menschen einzusetzen ist
entsetzlich und ein verbrechen
es ist daher gut dass im neuen
entlastungspaket auch eine milliarde
euro zur bewältigung der internationalen
ernährungskrise noch in diesem jahr
vorgesehen ist denn diese entwicklung
ist dramatisch und sie ist nur ein
vorbote dessen was uns 20 23 erwartet
und eine weltweite hungerkrise
abzuwenden hat deutschland das bündnis
für globale ernährungssicherheit
mitgegründet das bündnis wird
zusätzliche mittel für den kampf gegen
den hunger mobilisieren und die
internationalen anstrengungen in diesem
bereich bündeln und gleichzeitig hat das
bündnis auch langfristige ziele die
nahrungsmittelproduktion soll klima
angepasst nachhaltiger und
widerstandsfähiger werden und um
menschen vor armut und hunger zu
schützen braucht es weltweit mehr
soziale sicherungssystem und es braucht
auch die frauen in der gesellschaft denn
geschlechtergerechte gesellschaften sind
nicht nur gerechter sie sind auch
widerstandsfähiger dafür konnte ich mich
erst vor kurzem in kolumbien überzeugen
besonders einem gespräch mit betroffenen
die vom verschwinden lassen ihre
angehörigen betroffen sind das war
wirklich beeindruckend es ging mir sehr
nah und dabei ist sehr deutlich geworden
durch unsere zusammenarbeit können wir
aus opfern von gewalt gestalterinnen
gestalter der versöhnung machen nur so
kann nachhaltige entwicklung wirklich
gelingen wenn alle menschen gleiche
chancen unterstützung in notlagen und
ein gutes leben haben können die
deutsche entwicklungspolitik trägt
maßgeblich dazu bei den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt in
unseren partnerländern und ihre
resilienz zu stärken
die kolleginnen und kollegen die welt
schaut auf deutschland und sich schaut
genau hin wie wir alle uns in dieser
zeitenwende verhalten und positionieren
und es ist wichtig dass wir die ukraine
unterstützen und auch die vielen
menschen in den spielen in krisen
abseits des scheinwerferlichts wie zum
beispiel in den wieder aufflammenden
krieg um äthiopien und sie brauchen
unsere hilfe wir wollen die
zusammenarbeit in europa verstärken und
gleichzeitig auch die partnerländer
außerhalb europas im blick behalten und
mehr denn je muss deutschland jetzt
zeigen die solidarität der tat gilt auch
für den globalen süden wir stehen zu
unserer globalen verantwortung zu
unserem versprechen und zu den zielen
der agenda 2030 deutschland steht an der
seite unsere partnerländer auch in
diesen schwierigen zeiten und das ist
auch unser unmittelbares interesse es
geht darum die strukturellen
veränderungen einzuleiten sie umzusetzen
die jetzt erforderlich sind um die
menschliche sicherheit nachhaltig und
weltweit zu verbessern deutschland
braucht eine starke
entwicklungspolitik und ich hoffe darauf
ihre weitere unterstützung vielen dank
bundesministerin ist svenja schulze hat
hier zum einzelplan 23 gesprochen hat
unter anderem natürlich die
preissteigerungen und lieferengpässen
angesprochen denn auch das wurde hier
vor der debatte schon kritisiert die
überwindung des hungers bis 2030 könnte
in unerreichbare ferne rücken wenn nicht
zusätzlich geld dafür locker gemacht
wird folgt mal klein spricht jetzt für
die unionsfraktion
und verteidigungspolitik im laufe des
tages klar geworden
das wohl und wehe unseres landes hier in
deutschland ganz entscheidend von der
weiteren internationalen entwicklung
abhängt und
krisen zu bewältigen
und noch mehr krisen zu vermeiden
insoweit hat die ministerin mit ihren
schön klingenden worten gerade recht
gehabt ist aufgabe des bmz und darum
kümmern sich die engagierten
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
ministerium und in den vielen
organisationen die im namen und auf
rechnung deutschlands weltweit arbeiten
und das ist ja auch richtig so
weil
jenseits des ethischen auftrags oder
auch das gros christlicher nächstenliebe
das in der tat in unserem eigenen
deutschen interesse ist dass möglichst
krisen weitere krisen vermieden werden
und davon haben wir aber am holz unsere
ganze menge über die krise der
ernährungssicherheit wurde schon
gesprochen nach den ernteausfällen durch
russlands krieg in der ukraine ist das
ja überall und zwar weltweit vor allen
dingen in afrika spürbar
da müssen wir eigentlich mehr tun und
die ministerin hat jetzt überhaupt
nichts dazu gesagt dass sie aber als
bundesregierung mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf vorschlagen deutlich
weniger zu machen und weniger geld
auszugeben
allgemeine sicherheit und entwicklung in
der salz ohne war intensiv thema die
außenministerin hat dazu einiges gesagt
auch dackel
eigentlich im interesse unseres landes
müsste mehr getan werden
tatsächlich schlägt aber der
regierungsentwurf jetzt vor deutlich
weniger im einzelplan 23 auszugehen und
verbal scheint ja die regierung auch
dieser meinung zu sein jedenfalls
vollmundig ankündigungen zu machen
perfekte motor 1 für die regierung in
der realität sieht so ein bisschen
anders außen heute morgen hat friedrich
merz ja sehr eindrucksvoll beschrieben
dass die menschen kein vertrauen in den
bundeskanzler haben weil er seinen
worten eben keine taten folgen
und bei
serie ministerin bei der bmz ministerin
ist es eigentlich noch schlimmer und sie
weiß dass auch und versucht verzweifelt
dagegen anzugehen mit
einer deutlichen erhöhung der ausgaben
für ihre eigene öffentlichkeitsarbeit
und das aufblasen das aufblasen des
titels öffentlichkeitsarbeit des
ministeriums passt natürlich überhaupt
nicht in die landschaft wo insgesamt
10,2 prozent der mittel des ministeriums
gekürzt werden das ist los das triste
landschaft
ich bin mal gespannt ob die haushälter
der koalition die kraft haben diese
selbstgefälligkeit der ministerin
einzubremsen
nötig wäre ist und ich habe ja gerade
schon gesagt der einzelplan 23-jährigen
ist bunt 10,2 prozent wenn man als aber
komplett sich anschaut
inklusive
aus dem einzelplan 60 die vom bmz in
diesem jahr bewirtschaftet werden dann
ist die kürzung sogar 17 prozent
und mindestens kann man sagen dass ganz
schön viel intransparenz
ein wort im übrigen dass in dem gestern
vorgelegten bericht des
bundesrechnungshofs die entscheidende
rolle spielt ich lese mal vor was der
bundesrechnungshof zum einzelplan 23
gesagt hat ich zitiere die
veranschlagung der mittel für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist zunehmend
intransparent hauptgründe hierfür sind
die aufteilung dieser mittel auf den
einzelplan 23 um den einzelplan 60 sowie
die fehlerhafte veranschlagung von
leistungen multinationale usw
und genau das haben wir im frühjahr auch
schon kritisiert deswegen muss man
eigentlich sagen dass es nicht nur
intransparenz das ist vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen der versuch der
verschleierung um zu verschleiern wie
stark tatsächlich die mittel in diesem
bereich
dann hat mich ja fast gewundert dass
nicht eben schon kam aber wahrscheinlich
werden die kolleginnen und kollegen
gleich darauf hinweisen 5 milliarden
euro zusätzlich im einzelplan 60 für
globale mehrausgabe zur bewältigung an
dem i
so weiter
also
das ist aber an sich schon eine völlige
missachtung des parlaments
denn eigentlich gehört das aufgelöst in
dem haushalt damit wir das gutachten
können so ach so ist das so ist das team
gut und des finanzministers vorbehalten
und die kollegin hagedorn weist zu recht
darauf hin dass das durchaus einmal ein
mittel sein kann bei unvorhergesehen und
dingen aber hier ist es ja genau anders
herum weil wir stehen jetzt im
einzelplan 23 an vielen stellen weniger
wegen globaler krisen vorsorgen
das hat aber nichts mit einer noch
unbekannten wann die fällt der titel zu
tun sondern es hat damit zu tun dass die
koalition keine kraft hat bis aufzulösen
denn wenn die ministerinnen bei einer
ihrer ersten rede reisen in rom dem
world food programm zugesagt hat 70
millionen euro gibt es als kern bei
deutschlands und das jetzt plötzlich
wieder auf 23 reduziert wird mit dem
hinweis man habe ja krisenvorsorge
gedreht getan dann ist das genau das
gegenteil von wahrheit von haushalts
wahrheit und klarheit und so etwas
können wir nicht hinnehmen und
anschließend nach meinem verständnis als
haushälter der ich ja lange war können
die koalitions haushälter
so etwas auch nicht den herzlichen dank
volkmar klein war das hat schon im
vorfeld dieser debatte die
vorherrschende intransparent seiner
meinung nach kritisiert und jetzt in der
regel
kolleginnen und kollegen über 800
millionen menschen auf der welt jeder
zehnte leidet an hunger 800 millionen
menschen darunter viele kinder die
abends ohne gefüllten magen ins bett
gehen
seit beginn des krieges gegen die
ukraine mädchen alle seinen globalen
folgen für die ernährungssouveränität
sind 45 millionen menschen mehr geworden
und wenn wir uns heute fragen reicht das
was wir tun tun wir genug und wir uns
dann nur den einzelplan 23 mit den elf
milliarden euro anschauen dann wäre
vermutlich die ehrliche antwort das
reicht noch nicht meine damen und herren
ich habe mich dann eben dass wir im
frühjahr schon mal hier standen und zu
beginn eines haushalts verfahrens in der
ersten lesung auch unter den
demokratischen fraktionen gemeinsamen
analyse haken dass es nicht reicht und
es ist uns gelungen indem
haushaltsverfahren gemeinsam mit der
regierung und dem parlament mit einem
ergänzungs haushalt und klugen
umschichtungen dafür zu sorgen die
gelder zu stabilisieren und deswegen bin
ich sehr optimistisch und zuversichtlich
dass auch in diesem haushaltsverfahren
es uns gelingen wird den herausforderung
noch besser gerecht zu werden es ist
dieser erste und wo vielleicht vermuten
lassen mag und die ministerin und auch
ein klein
angesprochen die fünf milliarden euro
vorsorge im einzelplan 60 ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass es am ende
dieses haushaltsverfahren sehr klar sein
wofür wir diese gelder ausgeben und dass
die globale gerechtigkeit ein sehr
zentralen einen übergeordneten anschaut
an dieser globalen vorsorge eine
risikovorsorge einnehmen wird eben weil
es unsere verantwortung ist
meine damen und sternen es ist es heute
der 196
start des krieges gegen die ukraine ein
krieg der viel leid der tod und
zerstörung hinterlässt und in der
debatte vorher haben wir gerade viel
darüber diskutiert was betragen werden
kann mit waffenlieferung um die ukraine
militärisch zu unterstützen und das ist
richtig und es genau so richtig dass wir
geld dafür bereitstellen humanitäre
hilfe zu leisten
ernährungs unterstützung und vieles mehr
aber meine damen und herren die dritte
sollen das ist unsere aufgabe hier ist
schon jetzt in den wiederaufbau der
ukraine dieser nation zu investieren in
den wiederaufbau zerstörter
infrastruktur um die reparatur und die
residenz von zerstörten energienetzen in
infrastruktur damit kinder wieder zur
schule gehen können wenn wir wollen dass
die ukraine diesen krieg gegen russland
gewinnt und meine damen und herren dafür
ist diese unterstützung notwendig müssen
wir sie leisten und wir wollen dass sie
unter ihnen diesen krieg gegen die
russen
aber meine damen und herren im schatten
dieser akuten krisen der globalen
pandemie des krieges gegen die ukraine
und all seiner folgen lauert eine noch
viel gewaltiger herausforderungen für
das überleben der menschheit auf diesem
planeten die klima und die
biodiversitäts krise wir haben in diesem
sommer den vierten röhre sommer in fünf
jahren erlebt mit schrecklichen
auswirkungen schon hier wir haben vor
der sommerpause der opfer der toten der
flutkatastrophe in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen gedacht und im
sommer haben wir die schrecklichen
bilder aus pakistan erlebt und gesehen
über 1000 menschen sind gestorben mehr
als eine million häuser wurden zerstört
das was wir hier erleben erleben
menschen im globalen süden in aller
härte schon jetzt viel stärker und
deswegen ist es gut ist in diesem
haushaltsentwurf die vier milliarden
euro für internationalen klima
biodiversitätsschutz erst einmal
fortgeschrieben werden aber man haben
kann ich sehr deutlich das reicht noch
nicht aus wir falschen an diesem ziel
fest dass die koalition sich gegeben hat
ist ende der legislaturperiode
mindestens sechs milliarden euro für
internationalen klima- und
biodiversitätsschutz bereit zu stellen
weil es unsere verantwortung ist als
zielgröße industrienationen der
wohlstand so lange auf der verbrennung
fossiler rohstoffe aufgebaut hat und
leider noch immer aufbaut meine damen
und herren ich freue mich auf das
haushaltsverfahren ich bin optimistisch
dass wir am ende gemeinsam sagen können
es ist uns besser gelungen als vielen
vielen in der vergangenheit diesen
herausforderung gerecht zu werden vielen
dank
felix magath war das bündnis 90/die
grünen er sitzt wie auch der nächste
redner im haushaltsausschuss michael
aston villa hat nun das wort für die afg
fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube der etat des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung soll 2023
ausgaben in höhe von 11,1 milliarden
euro umfassen dazu kommen noch
verstärkung mittel im einzelplan 16 für
das bmz reserviert sind so dass das
ministerium im jahr 2023 ausgaben bis zu
16,1 milliarden euro tätigen kann das
sind 16 milliarden euro für die
internationale entwicklungshilfe die
2023 nicht in deutschland zur verfügung
stehen werden wie sie alle
wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen haben
sind das alles ausgaben die aufgrund der
derzeitig dramatisch steigenden
finanziellen belastung unserer eigenen
bevölkerung verstärkt anlass zur kritik
geben man hört dass gerade an jeder ecke
die menschen sagen dass es falsch ist so
viel geld ins ausland zu überweisen
während es bei uns rentner gibt die
trotz der tatsache dass sie ein leben
lang gearbeitet haben nicht von ihrer
rente leben können
[Applaus]
und diese menschen haben recht jedes
land hat die verpflichtung sich
zuallererst um seine eigene bevölkerung
zu kümmern
allerdings ein staat hat natürlich nicht
nur die aufgabe die grundbedürfnisse
seiner bevölkerung sicherzustellen
sondern muss auch sicherheit
gewährleisten und maßnahmen ergreifen
die das unterstützen eine gute
entwicklungshilfepolitik kann einen
beitrag leisten und krisenregionen in
der welt zu stabilisieren
krisenregionen die aufgrund ihrer
schlechten lebensbedingungen oft zum
nährboden für extremismus und
terrorismus werden und von denen dann
terroristische gefahren und
migrationsströme ausgehen die unser land
vor ernste sicherheitsprobleme stellen
aber es muss eben eine gute
entwicklungshilfepolitik seien eine
politik die deutschen interessen nutzt
und dabei internationale partner weder
überhöht noch wie unmündige kinder
behandelt sondern mit respekt und auf
augenhöhe
doch die entwicklungshilfepolitik
zeichnet sich dadurch gerade nicht aus
da stellt man fest wenn man sich abseits
des einzel plans 23 mal ein bisschen
einliest das habe ich diesen sommer
neben nicht gemacht und dabei ein
unglaublich erhellendes buch gefunden
das ich hier gerne allen empfehlen würde
es heißt ergänzt weit filmen und stammt
von der anwältinnen und aktivistin mafia
zaccaria kleine vorwarnung in der
deutschen übersetzung wird leider
geändert aber es lohnt sich trotzdem bei
frau zaccaria nämlich dem gesamten
system der westliche entwicklungshilfe
gesamtwerte geleitete aussenpolitik
einmal komplett die hosen runter zieht
kostprobe sie schreibt anstatt die
empfänger von hilfsprogramm zu ändern
also tatsächlich zu befähigen neigt die
entwicklungshilfe dazu ihre schützlinge
als hilflose
rückständige vor aufklärerische
versionen weißer westlicher frauen zu
betrachten deren soziale und kulturelle
unterschiede gegenüber dem westen
probleme sind die es zu lösen gilt sie
führt dann weiter aus dass die
entwicklungshilfe auf der grundlage der
fehleranalyse handelt dass die empfänger
der jeweiligen maßnahmen unwissend und
unpolitisch sein und keine eigenen ideen
oder überzeugung in bezug auf ihr
eigenes wohlergehen hätten damit legt
frau zaccaria den allen denen allen
entwicklungshilfe maßnahmen inhärenten
werte imperialismus des globalen lorenz
gegenüber dem globalen süden offen wenn
man das du dies zu dann versteht man
auch wie es dazu kommen konnte dass in
der internationalen politik derzeit ein
anti westlicher block entsteht wie die
welt das im juni bereits treffend
beschrieben hat auch der eu
außenbeauftragte
joseph [ __ ] l hat das nach seinem besuch
des g-20 außenministertreffens in bali
feststellen müssen wir geraten also
derzeit in einer situation in der der
globale süden eine neue selbstbewusste
stimme findet und deutschland in gefahr
gerät sich international zu isolieren
wenn wir einfach so weitermachen wie
bisher was machen wir also jetzt der
erste schritt muss sein dass wir die
grundlagen unserer entwicklungshilfe
politik und die einzelnen programme
endlich kritisch prüfen nicht nur auf
einsparpotentiale sondern auch darauf ob
sie ihren beabsichtigten sinn und zweck
erfüllen ich habe die bundesregierung
bei der letzten beratung dafür
kritisiert dass wir keinen überblick
darüber haben was eigentlich in welchem
land mit dem deutschen steuergeld so
alles passiert und siehe da afd wirkt
das versprechen versprochene transparenz
portal in dem er genau das zu dieser
frage findet ein da findet man
beantworten das kann sich auch jeder mal
anschauen dieses transparenz portal
gehen sie eigentlich mal einen bmz
transparenz portal bei google und sie
findet eine schöne nächste liste die hat
jetzt den stand vom 23 08 20 12 und 20
und umfasst sportliche 27
1749 einträge reicht aber auch bis ins
jahr 1995 zurück es wäre wünschenswert
wenn diese liste einmal im quartal
aktualisiert werden würde denn damit ist
tatsächlich ein großer schritt in sachen
transparenz getan kleiner seitenhieb
gegen die union warum gerd müller das
sind acht jahren regierungstätigkeit
nicht hingekriegt hat kann ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht nachvollziehen dass die
ampel ihnen jetzt den schneid abgekauft
ist auch schon ein bisschen unschöner
[Applaus]
mit diesem blickwinkel freuen wir uns
auf die beratung und kündigen jetzt
schon mal an dass wir wie auch beim
letzten mal änderungsanträge einbringen
werden vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
michael müller kündigt
änderungsanträge an und die änderungen
könnten natürlich auch in den debatten
in den entsprechenden ausschüssen
stattfinden und vorgebracht werden
claudia raffel schmerzmittel fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch beim
zweiten haushalt für unseren einzel 23
denen wir dieses jahr beraten bestimmt
die ukraine der ukraine krieg alle
überlegungen nachdem wir im frühsommer
bereits vom allerschlimmsten ausgehen
mussten konnten zwar doch wieder einige
getreide lieferungen die ukraine
verlassen aber auch die sind nur tropfen
auf den heißen stein und sie sollten uns
nicht davon ablenken dass dieser krieg
für den westen buchstäblich ein
warnschuss ist denn klar ist mit der
bisherigen strategie gegen
ernährungskrisen kommen wir nicht weiter
wir brauchen weniger abhängigkeit von
weizen importe aus der ukraine und aus
russland und wir brauchen mehr resilienz
insbesondere afrikanischer staaten und
mehr anbau von besser geeigneten
nahrungsmitteln in den regionen
was sie außerdem brauchen ist mehr
privatwirtschaftliches engagement gerne
mit unterstützung durch die
bundesregierung es ist jedoch nicht
aufgabe des bmz jedes unternehmerische
risiko eines jeden deutschen investments
in einem entwicklungsland abzufedern
gerade im bereich der erneuerbaren
energien gibt es auch so enorme chancen
für beide seiten
denn wir sollten mit blick auf unseren
einzelplan so ehrlich sein zu sehen
weder mittel noch mit 12 noch mit 100
milliarden euro wird deutschland die
welt retten es ist leider so
umgekehrt wird aber ein schuh draus wir
müssen den knapp 11,1 milliarden euro
des kabinetts entwurfs noch besser
wirtschaften und die große größtmögliche
wirkung entfalten und ich bin sicher
dass es hier noch erhebliches potenzial
gibt ein wichtiger punkt wäre der abbau
von bürokratie
evaluation transparenz dürfen nicht zum
selbstzweck werden gerade für kleine und
mittlere akteure das berichten private
träger immer wieder nimmt die
dokumentationspflichten einen zu großen
teil ihrer zeit ein die dann in der
praktischen arbeit am projekt fair
daneben müssen wir aber auch die frage
welche infos überhaupt wann und mit
welchen konkreten aufgaben eingesetzt
werden immer wieder neu stellen denn mit
blick auf die unglücklichen ausgängen
der westlichen missionen afghanistan und
in mali sollten wir die selben fehler in
der ukraine tunlichst vermeiden so kam
ein bericht des französischen instituts
für internationale beziehungen im juni
diesen jahres zu sehr sehr ernüchternden
ergebnissen die in juno seien zu wenig
lokal vernetzt und vor allem viel zu
pauschal und unflexibel in ihrem
vorgehen in verschiedenen krisenregionen
dieser welt hier sollten wir noch mal
ganz ganz genau hinschauen es geht nur
mich wohl die märkte nicht darum weniger
hilfe zu leisten sondern die hilfe
besser koordinierte und effektiver zu
machen und eben weil das geld dass wir
verteilen können nicht unbedingt mehr
wird ob country falls also
länderspezifische aufstellung über
hilfsgelder sind ein wichtiges
instrument das die bundesregierung
unbedingt nutzen sollte
der ukraine krieg zeigt deutlich dass
westliche region regierung nicht nur bei
den militärischen interventionen gefragt
sind auch die zivile krisenbewältigung
und instabil ihre stabilisierungsprozess
dürfen wir nicht komplett an die endlos
outsourcen sondern müssen aktiv
mitgestalten und kritisch bewerten dazu
gehört auch dazu gehört auch dass wir
unsere wolle international selbstbewusst
ausfüllen die idee dass deutschland als
zweitgrößte geber nation mit gutem
beispiel vorangeht und andere länder
quasi automatisch folgen klingt zwar gut
hat aber leider in den letzten jahren
nicht immer funktioniert ein blick auf
die entwicklung der oder quoten zeigt
die deutsche oder ist seit 2008 zehn
gestiegen und lag
2022 bei
0,76 prozent im selben zeitraum lag
großbritannien stabil bei 0,33 und
frankreich bei maximalen 0,53 prozent
tendenz wieder feind die usa sind zwar
größtes geberland in absoluten zahlen
kommen aber nur auf eine recht
bescheidene oda quote von ich sag mal
lächerlichen
0,18 prozent mein praktikum ist daher
dass wir unser statt das engagement
aufrechterhalten
zugleich aber die anderen geberländer an
ihre aufgaben erinnern
denn sie tun gibt es eine menge neben
den guten krisen dürfen wir nicht die
alten herausforderung vergessen allen
voran ex polio tuberkulose und malaria
letztere sind in afrika ein viel
größeres problem als poet und daher
sollten wir dafür sorgen dass uns beim
kampf gegen diese vier krankheiten nicht
das geld und nicht die puste ausgehen
damit kommen wir zu
sprechen für entwicklungspolitik der
linksfraktion cornelia möhring hat jetzt
als band
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen afghanistan
ukraine jemand diese länder namen stehen
für krieg und leid am horn von afrika
sind laut un über 200.000 menschen vom
hungertod bedroht die nachrichten von
dürren und hinzu toten werden abgelöst
von nachrichten von überschwemmungen und
flutopfern die folgen des klimawandels
werden immer drastischer
klimakatastrophe ist jetzt die
bundesregierung könnte und müsste
eigentlich den multiplen krisen in der
welt mit gezielten investitionen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit humanitäre
hilfe und internationale
klimafinanzierung begegnen sie tun das
aber nicht ausreichend schlimmer noch
die anderen 14
jungs zusammenarbeit auf den stand von
vor corona ich halte das für fahrlässig
und verantwortungslos
und frau ministerin schulze sie bauen
auf unsere unterstützung sagen sie und
die haben sie ja auch in vielen vielen
punkten aber es ist mir entwurf den sie
hier vorlegen mit all den darin
enthaltenen kürzungen und sie haben
diesen entwurf im kabinett zugestimmt
ich erwarte herrliche stammt von einer
ministerin entwicklungszusammenarbeit
ein paar deutlichere töne für die
bessere ausstattung dieses einzel plans
deutschland gehört zu den
industrienationen als industrienationen
zu den hauptverantwortlichen des
klimawandels und hat einen erheblichen
anteil am zustand unserer erde und den
stetig sich verschärfen denn vielfach
krisen dieser verantwortung werden sie
nicht gerecht vor dem krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine litten bereits über
800 millionen menschen an chronischen
hunger weltweit stirbt alle 13 sekunden
ein kind unter fünf jahren an hunger
sowie 19 hat dabei wie ein
brandbeschleuniger für die weltweite
hungerkrise gewirkt auch andere
konflikte und krisen werden ebenso
beschleunigen und trotzdem werden
deutsche waffen in den krisenregionen
dieser welt abgefeuert letztes jahr
wurden waffen exporte im wert von 9,4
milliarden euro genehmigt das ist laut
wirtschaftsministerium ein historischer
höchststand und wovon die
rüstungsindustrie hier profitiert das
ist das leid anderer weltweit und nun
sollen auch noch die mittel für das welt
währungs programm von 70 millionen auf
28 millionen gekürzt werden auf den
betrag den es forderten akademie
erhalten hat als wären mittlerweile
nichts geschehen und ihre worten und
taten dürften auch in anderen fragen
auseinander sie predigen diplomat ihren
multilateralismus aber streichen weil
eben die mittel für die un und ihre
organisationen um fast 50 prozent das
kinderhilfswerk unicef soll nur noch 60
millionen statt der bisherigen 140
millionen erhalten ich frage sie
ministerin schulze was senden sie dafür
falsche signale okay das ist zugegeben
eine rhetorische frage denn die antwort
lautet fürs militär werden mal schnell
100 milliarden sondervermögen locker
gemacht für die verheerungen in der welt
bleibt nicht genügend übrig ein
wettersystem bekommt mehr als acht mal
so viel wie das welternährungsprogramm
denn im juli rund
242 millionen für den ausbau des
waffensystems eurofighter ausgegeben
nichts zeigt ihre falschen prioritäten
so deutlich und das globale
strukturproblem der
nahrungsmittelversorgung anzugehen
braucht es ein strukturwandel hin zur
ernährungssouveränität und dafür sind
über jahre größere investitionen nötig
dafür und für eine effektive
krisenintervention müssten sie sich aber
mit den profiteuren dieser zahlreichen
krisen anlegen mit den transnationalen
konzernen mit den nahrungsmittel
spekulanten mit den satten exporteuren
den pharmakonzern den produzenten
fossile energien sie müssen sich viel
konsequenter in europa und global dafür
einsetzen der steueroasen geschlossen
werden schulden erlassen und reichtum
umverteilt wird leider sehe ich da auch
anzeichen sie sich an diese gegner ran
trauen ihr haushaltsentwurf spiegelt er
die neoliberale politik die gleichzeitig
durch ursache dieser krisen ist der
haushalt trägt die handschrift der fdp
ist aber mit der unfähigkeit von spd und
grünen unterschrieben nämlich mit der
unfähigkeit dass sie gegen ihren
pflanzen koalitionspartner wenigstens
ein haushalt durchsetzen der den eigenen
koalitionsvertrag umsetzen würde und die
will kollegen und kollegen die zeit
läuft aber davon die welt ist in einem
ausnahmezustand
es ist an der zeit für außergewöhnliche
maßnahmen schnelles handeln das sagte
doch so richtig der club of rome letzte
woche und bringt es dann auf den punkt
ohne umverteilung des reichtums kann die
klimakrise kann die ungleichheit nicht
bekannt beendet werden ja die zeit läuft
davon und mit diesem haushalt leisten
sie keinen beitrag um dem
entgegenzuwirken
die welt ist im ausnahmezustand und sie
sollten ihre prioritäten dringend ändern
es darf keine kürzungen im etat für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit humanitäre
hilfe und internationale
klimafinanzierung geben von uns aus
dafür gerne im rüstungsetat vielen dank
dr
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegin kam es heute schon gehört
bekommen in einer zeit zusammen
vielschichtiger und komplexer krisen
diese krisen sind global
die zeitenwende zeigt noch einmal mehr
dass eindimensionales in
nationalstaatliches denken wie bis heute
schon von ganz weg gehört haben längst
vorbei ist die werkzeuge klassischen
politiker klassischen politik ressorts
sind der komplexität der aktuellen
internationalen krisen nicht gewachsen
umso mehr brauchen wir eine struktur
bildende entwicklungspolitik die
zentrale des ohrs wie wirtschaftsklima
und bildungspolitik vereint und die
richtigen werkzeuge bereit hält und
anwendet und diese krisen zu bewältigen
wer damit dies auch funktioniert
benötigen einen solide finanzierten bmz
haushalt und ja so ehrlich muss man sein
der jetzige regierungsentwurf in höhe
von 11,0 milliarden reicht dafür nicht
aus
um den internationalen herausforderungen
gerecht zu werden muss dieser
haushaltsentwurf an die realität
angepasst und deutlich aufgestockt
werden
in diesen tagen endet ein weiterer
sommer herr klein dazu kommen wir gleich
noch mal
in diesen ich rede ja normal weiter
vielleicht hören sie auf zu in diesen
tagen endet ein weiterer sommer der zu
den wärmsten seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen gehört und wenn wir in
der vergangenheit über die folgen der
klimakrise gesprochen haben so dachten
wir oft allein in die region des
globalen südens wir dachten an die dürre
im norden kenias an die brände deswegen
weitesten lateinamerika und an
verheerende überschwemmungen wie derzeit
in pakistan haben es gerade gehört die
räumliche distanz erleichtert vielen
eine verdrängung dieser schrecklichen
ereignisse doch die extremen folgen der
klimakrise
schädigung
sind ganz deutlich bei unserer eigenen
haustür angekommen die waldbrände in
brandenburg die extreme dürre in
frankreich die vielen mit zu toten und
die schreckliche hochwasserkatastrophe
mitte letzten jahres anna und erft
spätestens jetzt muss doch jeder noch so
liberale wirtschaftsweise verstanden
haben dass eine hohe finanzierung des
klimaschutzes nicht im widerspruch mit
einem wohl bewirtschafteten haushalt
steht ganz im gegenteil denn die folgen
der klimakrise betont neben unserer
sicherheit auch unseren
wirtschaftssystem
geführt die außergewöhnliche türe dieses
sommers zu einem extrem niedrigen
wasserstand des rheins güterschiffe
concours in teillast fahren und wichtige
energie transporte fielen aus sie alle
sollten daraus lernen unsere
lieferketten langfristig zu schützen und
solche ereignisse unwahrscheinlicher zu
machen brauchen wir einen gut
finanzierten internationalen klimaschutz
und das muss sich dringend im haushalt
des bmz widerspiegeln der klimawandel
verstärkt auch die globale
ernährungskrise und die gravierenden
folgen des russischen angriffskriegs auf
die ukraine verschlimmern die situation
nochmal mehr kürzlich sind endlich nach
langem warten erste transportschiff aus
den ukrainischen häfen damit getreide an
bord ausgelaufen und ministerin svenja
schulze warnte an dieser stelle völlig
zurecht vor einer zu grossen euphorie
denn die strukturellen probleme bleiben
die getreidepreise sind noch immer viel
zu hoch und werden durch lebensmittel
spekulationen des finanzsektors weiter
angetrieben das globale ernährungssystem
muss von grund auf reformiert werden um
nachhaltige und krisenfeste strukturen
zu schaffen und unser ziel muss eine
langfristige ernährungssouveränität
unserer partnerländer seien
daher bin ich froh ich bin froh dass wir
mit dem dritten entlastungspaket bis zu
eine milliarde euro dafür zusätzlich
bereitstellen diese gelder werden
dringend gebraucht denn sie retten leben
wer ist dann am stärksten von hunger
betroffen es sind weltweit 150 millionen
mehr frauen als männer
wir wissen wenn frauen die gleiche
entscheidungsmacht haben die männer sind
der hunger und es gibt einen festeren
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt und auch
deswegen begrüßen wir die starke für
minister entwicklungspolitik in bern
die kürzung der haushaltstitel bereich
der vereinten nationen ist eine der
zentralen schwächen dieses entwurfs wir
können wie können wir in einer zeit in
der wert bei kinderarmut steigt die
gelder für unicef kürzen in einer zeit
in der weltweiten pandemie die gelder
für die impf allianz gaben in einer zeit
in der gewalt gegen frauen drastisch
zunimmt die gelder für die un women das
können wir nicht verantworten und wir
senden damit die falsche botschaft in
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
in einer zeit in der multilateralismus
wichtiger ist denn die
die entwicklungspolitik nimmt die
perspektiven wir stehen am anfang der
haushaltsverhandlungen ich glaube da ist
noch viel arbeit und zeit drin die
entwicklungspolitik nimmt die
perspektiven der partnerländer ein um
einen kooperativen und
gleichberechtigten umgang zu
gewährleisten es muss klar sein das
entwicklungspolitische geldern das
möchte ich hier in aller deutlichkeit
noch mal sagen keine wohltätigen spenden
sind ganz im gegenteil es sind gelder
die uns ermöglichen eine
partnerschaftliche internationale
zusammenarbeit zu gewährleisten und der
von der wir in deutschland langfristig
profitieren
vorsichtige haushaltskürzung haben
drastisch und langfristig internationale
konsequenzen die wir uns keineswegs
erlauben können denn erstens in zeiten
komplexer krisen gerät die
entwicklungspolitik in den mittelpunkt
des politischen geschehens und sie hält
die richtigen politischen werkzeuge
bereit zweitens die zeit des
paternalistischen top-down denkens ist
vorbei die kooperation mit unseren
partnerländern ist gleichberechtigt und
multilateralen die kürzung von geldern
im bereich der un organisation geht hier
in die falsche richtung auch die
schuldenbremse kann eine solche kürzung
nicht rechtfertigen denn wenn wir jetzt
zögerlich handeln haben wir morgen
riesige folgekosten für die eu und für
deutschland
drittens eine progressive zweiten wende
steht auch für mehr konflikt präventive
entwicklungspolitik denn wir reden hier
immer noch von nachhaltiger
friedenspolitik ich möchte zum schluss
kommt seit jahren sind wir hier in
diesem wohnhaus getriebene verpasster
prävention im alter hatte passten
hochwasserschutz in der pandemie
verfehlte bevorratung mit medizinischem
material in der aktuellen krise fehlende
energie alternativen und immer sagen wir
hätten wir damals mal in der entwicklung
die politik ich komm zum letzten satz in
entwicklungspolitik ist jetzt der moment
dem den zukunft entweder bereuen werden
oder indem wir uns eine krise der
zukunft ersparen dafür reiche aktuellen
regierungsentwurf nicht aus aber ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir hier klarer
nachlassen vielen dank
sanaa ab die warnte unter anderem vor
einem top down ansatz also regelung von
oben nach unten in der gesellschaft
durchdrücken zu wollen in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
wolfgang steffen hat kann jetzt direkt
auf sie antworten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der haushalt des
entwicklungsministeriums ist kurzsichtig
und nicht ehrgeizig mit einem wort
ambitionslos frau ministerin es wurde
wieder deutlich und dieser haushalt
zementiert es auch in den fehlt es an
der vision nach einem jahr im ist immer
noch nicht klar wo sie hinwollen und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
insbesondere von fdp und von den grünen
hätten wir als union in den vergangenen
jahren so einen haushaltsentwurf hier
eingebracht wir werden zurecht zu recht
von ihnen zerrissen worden in der
debatte
wenn wir die wenn ich mir die debatten
der letzten wahlperiode anschauen
insbesondere die forderungen von grünen
und fdp mehr multilaterale
zusammenarbeit stärkung der wirtschafts
kooperationen stärkung der vereinten
nationen da muss ich feststellen in
diesem haushalt die beiträge sinken sie
sinken teils um fünfzig prozent die im
quali ansgar wie sogar um 74 prozent des
kinderhilfswerk unicef und 57 prozent
global partnership on education um 21%
ich frage mich wo ist denn ihr aufschrei
sie haben hier in den letzten jahren
unsere aufwüchse als zu gering
kritisiert und nun kürzen sie massiv sie
kürzen massiv bei gesundheit massiv bei
kindern massiv bildung kann nur eines
sagen nicht an den worten sondern an
ihren taten sollt ihr sie müssen
frau ministerin was ist aus ihrer
feministischen
entwicklungspolitik geworden es war eine
schlagzeile gut kürzlich haben sie uhr
im moment sehr gelobt für den einsatz
und gleichstellung der geschlechter als
grundvoraussetzung für eine nachhaltige
entwicklung ist es wichtig so ein sehr
wichtiger punkt aber der beitrag für un
women sinkt um 25 prozent ich kann nur
allen organisationen dringend raten
vorsicht wenn diese ministerin sie lobt
dann ist vorsicht geboten
dann heißt es ohren anlegen warm
anziehen und den sparstrumpf rausholen
das ist die realität
seit es die welternährung wir haben die
größte hungersnot seit jahrzehnten durch
den angriffskrieg von russland auf die
ukraine erst kürzlich habe ich sie dafür
gelobt dass sie 880 millionen euro
sondermittel für den kampf gegen den
hunger bereitgestellt haben das ist
einmalig kann man muss man auch positiv
erwähnen sie haben sich in dem jahr
sogar selber dafür gelobt dass das world
food programm jetzt langfristig planen
und wirtschaften könnte ich frage sie
gilt diese langfristige planung ab dem
neujahrstag
2023 nicht mehr sie sagten vorhin hunger
ist grausam ja das ist so aber für den
nächsten haushalt kürzen sie beim kern
beitrag für das welternährungsprogramm
um mehr als 60% sie kürzen bei der
sonder initiative eine welt ohne hunger
um 150 millionen wo ist hier die
langfristige planung und wie steht es
denn um die zuverlässigkeit deutschlands
als internationaler partner ich kann
ihnen die antwort geben schlecht steht
es darum spannend übrigens frau
ministerin finde ich ja die
parteiübergreifende petition von
ehemaligen vorsitzenden des
entwicklungsausschusses mit der
überschrift und dem eindringlichen
appell lasst sie nicht verhungern
hier fordern professor holz von der spd
früherer entwicklungsausschuss
vorsitzender thilo hoppe von den grünen
dagmar wöhrl und peter ramsauer von der
unionsfraktion und der derzeitige
amtierende vorsitzende mein geschätzter
fdp-kollege hoffmann dass die
bundesregierung die mittel angesichts
der welternährungskrise nicht kürzen
soll ich glaube das ist ein einmaliger
vorgang dass mitglieder von parteien die
diese bundesregierung tragen sich mit
einer petition an den deutschen
bundestag wenden weil diese regierung
nicht handle die
frau ministerin termin ihrer rede eine
zustandsbeschreibung gemacht ja sie
haben recht es gibt einen haufen krisen
auf der welt und hier müssen wir auch
was tun wir auch eine neue weltlage das
ist richtig aber durchwurschteln geht
hier nicht wo sind die ihre antworten
für die krisenbewältigung und die
stabilisierung von staaten es gibt immer
mehr krisen auf der welt sie kürzen den
titel was ist dieser plan für neue jobs
in entwicklungsländern wie wollen sie
denn den tourismus wieder aufbauen der
nach corona eingebrochen ist millionen
menschen haben ihren job verloren ihre
lebensgrundlage verloren was ist mit den
wirtschafts- kooperationen was es mit
dem begonnenen erfolgreichen bildungs
und forschungskooperationen was es mit
den energie partnerschaften mit den
afrikanischen ländern andere staaten
sind hier aktiv
wie wollen sie denn die landwirtschaft
in der entwicklungs in
entwicklungsländern stärken und haben
sie mit ihrer spd-kollegin lamprecht
eigentlich auch einmal über den
vernetzten ansatz gesprochen entwicklung
braucht sicherheit und ohne entwicklung
gibt es keine dauerhafte sicherheit von
ministerin nach einem jahr im amt hätten
sie mit diesem haushalt wirkliche
akzente setzen können schade sie haben
es nicht getan
und was sie sich aber kümmern ist die
weitere aufblähung des hauses noch mal
ein und 20 neue stellen im haushalt ich
frage mich für was der titel
öffentlichkeitsarbeit es schon
angesprochen worden aber womöglich sagen
sie sich marketing ist alles wenn ich
politisch nichts mache dann möchte ich
wenigstens gut dabei aussehen das reicht
aber nicht das reicht aber nicht
angesichts der weltweiten lage frau
ministerin sie reißen viele science sie
reißen vieles an was wir in den
vergangenen acht jahren in der großen
koalition
aufgebaut haben ich darf sie daran
erinnern dass sie da mit dabei waren von
16 jahren regierung und sie zwölf jahre
mit an bord wir haben sehr viel
aufgebaut und sehr viel erreicht und
sich reißen hier vieles ein das ist sehr
sehr schade sie werden der rolle
deutschlands in der welt in keiner weise
gerecht
sehr deutlich kritik von wolfgang
steffel cdu csu unter anderem kritik an
der öffentlichkeitsarbeit
deborah döring spricht diese sprecherin
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung der bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die
ministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie in haushaltsverhandlungen
diskutieren wir häufig über abstrakte
zahlen wir schieben summen von a nach b
und dabei lauert die gefahr dass wir
vergessen welche auswirkungen dieses
verschieben in konkreten fällen hat alle
dreieinhalb sekunden
verhungert aktuell ein mensch jetzt
jetzt
und jetzt
ist der hunger eltern kinder junge und
alte menschen sie sterben im jemen in
afghanistan integra und in somalia
die hungersnöte haben interne und
externe ursachen bewaffnete konflikte
die folgen der klimakrise eine extreme
ungleiche verteilung von land und
abhängigkeiten von märkten des globalen
nordens es sind koloniale strukturen die
diese ursachen bis heute prägen und es
sind multiple krisen die sich
gegenseitig verschärfen wir als
weltgemeinschaft haben mit den zielen
für nachhaltige entwicklung den sts
versprochen für ein besseres leben für
alle menschen zu kämpfen
20.30 sollen wir den hunger ausrotten
stattdessen kommt ständig neue
hungersnöte hinzu wir wollen bis 20.30
die armut global beenden
stattdessen ist seit beginn der korona
pandemie und verstärkt durch den krieg
in der ukraine die absolute armut in der
welt um ein viertel gestiegen bis ende
diesen jahres werden circa
860 millionen menschen von weniger als
einem dollar 90 pro tag leben müssen das
sind mehr als zehn prozent der gesamten
weltbevölkerung
und während wir in deutschland zu recht
über wasser sparen reden sind in anderen
teilen der welt praktisch ganze gegenden
unbewohnbar geworden die klimakrise
sinkt jährlich circa 26 millionen
menschen zuflucht bis 2050 soll es über
140 millionen klima geflüchtet weltweit
geben
und egal wo wir hinschauen
manchmal habe ich das gefühl wir laufen
in die komplett falsche richtung
und liebe opposition ja wir können uns
jetzt hier gegenseitig vorwerfen was wir
gemacht haben oder was wir auch nicht
gemacht haben vielleicht in den 16
jahren und glauben sie mir wir würde
genug einfallen aber davon wird kein
einziger mensch mehr zugang zu wasser
mehr zugang zu grundbildung und mehr im
zugang zur gesundheitsversorgung haben
und dass das ist auch unser gemeinsames
ziel hier unser ziel ist es doch dass
wir aktuelle krisen bekämpfen und
präventiv kommende krisen verhindern ja
dafür brauchen wir eine angemessene
finanzielle ausstattung des bmz etats
und es haben sich schon gehört davon
sind wir noch sehr weit entfernt
aber dafür brauchen wir auch
strukturelle veränderungen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
humanitäre hilfe können krisen abmildern
entwicklungszusammenarbeit kann einen
beitrag dazu leisten residente
strukturen aufzubauen bei der
ernährungssouveränität beim ausbau von
bildungs- und gesundheitssystem beim
schutz der biodiversität oder beim
abfedern der folgen der klimakrise aber
entwicklungszusammenarbeit arbeit kann
nicht eine fehlgeleitete handels oder
finanzpolitik und struktureller
abhängigkeiten ausmerzen
und genau deswegen ist es unsere
verantwortung für globale gerechtigkeit
in allen bereichen in allen häusern
weltweit zu kämpfen
es ist ein richtiges signal dass die
bundesregierung im entlastungspaket am
wochenende auch eine milliarde euro
zusätzlich im laufenden haushalt für den
kampf gegen die hungerkrise zugesagt hat
und es ist gut dass im 163 4 20 23 jetzt
5 milliarden euro für krisenbedingte
mehrausgaben vorgesehen sind dabei muss
es aber auch unser ziel sein krisen
nachhaltig und langfristig zu bekämpfen
und eben nicht nur zu lindern und für
den haushalt des bmz sieht es ehrlich
gesagt ganz schön düster aus fürs
kommende jahr es kann nicht sein dass
wir uns so aus der verantwortung stehlen
es kann nicht sein dass wir in
anbetracht wachsen der krisen den
entwicklungsetat kürzen wir kommen
gleich zu den löwen vorschlag keine
angst jeder euro der in die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit investiert
wird hilft krisen zu verhindern
krisen
krisen die zu konflikten werden
konflikte die uns auch in deutschland
direkt betreffen und nur zur erinnerung
wir haben einen koalitionsvertrag und in
dem haben wir ganz vorausschauend uns
darauf geeinigt dass die ausgaben für
verteidigung und die ausgaben für
entwicklung und humanitäre hilfe und
auswärtige kulturpolitik im selben maße
ansteigen
im ersten regierungsentwurf bleibt
ehrlich gesagt noch eine ganz schön
große lücke aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
glücklicherweise ist das haushaltsrecht
ja parlamentsrechte und deswegen
herrscht effinger sie haben das ja
gerade schon angesprochen lade ich sie
herzlich dazu ein wie die kollegen hofft
man und die ehemaligen abz vorsitzende
es eben schon getan haben in den
kommenden wochen als demokratische
fraktion gemeinsam für einen haushalt zu
kämpfen der den aktuellen krisen mittel
und langfristig gerecht wird dann ist
nämlich unsere verantwortung
einzustehen
und in nächster redner hier eine debatte
zum einzelplan 23 ist edgar new york für
die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
doch die junge
seine frau präsidentin haben sie vielen
dank für das wort werde kollegen liebe
zuschauer das königsrecht des parlaments
ist das den haushalt zu bestimmen und zu
beschließen heute debattieren wir über
den haushalt des bundesministeriums für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung kurz auch bmz ich möchte bei
dieser gelegenheit daran erinnern dass
jedem recht auch eine pflicht gegenüber
steht wie bereits erwähnt ist das das
höchste recht des parlaments über den
staatshaushalt zu befinden
diesem recht folgt aber auch die pflicht
sorgsam und verantwortungsvoll mit den
steuergeldern unsere bürger umzugehen
gerade in unserer krisenhaften situation
ist das mehr als angebracht äußerst
sparsam und effizient zu handeln da hier
von der regierung vorgelegte entwurf für
den haushalt das bmz erfüllt diese
pflichten aber offenkundig nicht
entwurf sieht vor dem bmz für das jahr
2023 ganze elf milliarden euro zur
verfügung zu stellen dass es angesichts
unserer politischen und wirtschaftlichen
lage in keiner weise vertretbar
für mich grenzt das schon an staatlich
organisierter verschwendung von
steuergeldern
kein problem der deutschen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist dass sich
schlichtweg unwirksam ist wer leisten
seit jahrzehnten hilfe haben zig
milliarden euro in der welt verteilt und
mit welchem ergebnis
müsste sich die entwicklungshilfe nach
mehr als 60 jahren nicht bereits selbst
überflüssig gemacht haben die
wirkungslosigkeit unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit hat viele
gründe und diese sind überwiegend
hausgemacht allen voran besteht weder im
ministerium noch in der
durchführungsorganisationen eine gesunde
fehlerkultur das führt dazu dass nahezu
alle umgesetzten projekte zumindest auf
dem papier als erfolgreich bewertet
werden aber offensichtlich entspricht
das nicht der realität
umso wichtiger ist dass hier transparenz
zu schaffen der bundestag mit seiner
pflicht zur kontrolle in das bmz
nachkommen und deutlich mehr
rechenschaft einfordern bevor weitere
mittel bewilligt werden
hierzu müssen wir das deutsche
evaluierungs institute
entwicklungszusammenarbeit stärken dass
die wahl benötigt eine bessere
finanzielle ausstattung mehr kompetenzen
und befugnisse sowie mehr unabhängigkeit
vom ministerium entsprechende anträge
werden wir in haushaltsverhandlungen
einbringen erfolgreicher deutscher
entwicklungspolitik wird nur mit
vernunft statt ideologie möglich
moralische erpressung und selbstbetrug
sind nicht der richtige weg vielmehr
muss gelten mut zur wahrheit vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp
was man isst entwicklungspolitische
sprecher der fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
präsidentin gesetzte kolleginnen und
kollegen
seitenwände heißt für mich wir
korrigieren eine fehlentwicklung die wir
durch vernachlässigung der verteidigung
vor allem in den letzten beiden
jahrzehnten politisch zu verantworten
haben
seitenwände heißt für mich aber auch
unsere gesamte sicherheitsarchitektur
neu aufzustellen und das ist viel mehr
als verteidigung das betrifft alle
unsere internationalen beziehungen nur
zur globalen kooperationen also die
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung und diese kooperationen und
die zusammenarbeit auf vielen ebenen
müssen künftig wachsen damit wir in
weiteren zehn oder zwanzig jahren nicht
erneut vernachlässigungen korrigieren
müssen die uns sonst
sicherheitspolitisch auf die zehen
fallen
für unsere diskussion zum haushalt 2023
bedeutet das es ist gut wenn die
bundesregierung die sich über die
verteilung der mittel im rahmen der
möglichkeiten einigen muss der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch diese
wichtigkeit zuordnet jetzt und in den
folgenden jahren und ich bin sicher dass
unsere bundesministerin svenja schulze
auch diese position vertritt und der im
kabinett geltung verschafft
und da sieht es für den haushalt 2023 so
schlecht nicht aus wie es hier manchmal
dargestellt wurde denn im rahmen der
möglichkeiten heißt unter einhaltung der
grund gesetzlich vorgegebenen und im
koalitionsvertrag zusätzlich noch einmal
ausdrücklich genannten schuldenbremse
und da wir in anwendung der in den
schuldenbremse festgelegten
notsituationen in den letzten drei
jahren erhöhte schulden aufgenommen und
damit logischerweise erhöhte haushalte
beschlossen haben dürfen wir ihn hier
vorgelegten haushalt nicht ganz einfach
so mit den vorjahren vergleichen sondern
müssen in einem sinnvollen vergleich auf
das jahr 2009 10 zurückgehen daran
gemessen haben wir einen ordentlichen
aufwuchs der mittel für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit von 10,8 zehn
milliarden im jahr 2019 auf 11,08
milliarden euro jetzt und es gibt ja
noch spielräume aus dem einzelplan 60
die genannt worden sind und die wollen
wir auch heute den weiteren
verhandlungen auch nutzen damit am ende
auch ein ordentliches plus steht
erleben erlauben sie mir noch ein wort
seine besonderen teil unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die mittel
für die verwaltung der palästinensischen
gebiete im nahen osten und damit
zusammenhängenden institutionen auch die
unsäglichen äußerungen des
palästinensischen repräsentanten hier in
berlin sozusagen in sicht und rufweite
zum denkmal für die ermordeten juden
europas möchte ich nicht weiter eingehen
ich beziehe mich lieber auf die
beeindruckende rede des
staatspräsidenten israels gestern hier
vor dem hohen haus darin hat sich
präsident herzog in eindrücklicher weise
und ausdrücklich zur verantwortung für
die palästinensischen bürger seines
starts und der nachbarschaft israels
bekannt nein ihm auch dafür standing
ovations gegeben damit unsere
unterstützung für diese krisen gequälte
region gezeigt das heißt für mich wir
haben immer schon genau hingeschaut wie
unsere ez mittel dort eingesetzt werden
wir werden künftig noch genauer
hinschauen müssen weil wir fest an der
seite des jüdischen staates stehen die
in ihrer freiheitlich demokratischen
ordnung zu unseren engsten partnern in
der welt zählt
wir freie demokraten werden darauf
achten dass alle parlamentarischen
kontrolle möglichkeiten die wir haben
sorgfältig und konsequent genutzt werden
um sicherzustellen dass kein deutsches
steuergeld zur förderung von terrorismus
und hetze gegen juden im nahen osten
zweckentfremdet werden kann vielen dank
[Applaus]
mit in der hand und hat jetzt das wort
und sie spricht für die spd-fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen ich jetzt meine eigentliche
jedem an die seite weil ich muss ja doch
mal ein paar märchen aufräumen da bin
ich mich zunächst an meinen geschätzten
kollegen volkmar klein der sich her
geoutet hat als langjähriges mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss das stimmt aber umso
enttäuschter weiß über die vertreten
tatsachen die angeblichen jährige
berichtet hat denn nicht nur dass den
regierungsentwurf 20 23 mit dem
beschlossenen haushalt 20 22 verglichen
hat wenn er den regierungsentwurf mit
dem regierungsentwurf verglichen hätte
wäre wäre er hier zu ganz anderen
ergebnissen kommen denn nach dem
parlamentarischen verfahren haben wir ja
den einzelplan der ministerin zu recht
massiv erhöht das andere ist dass der
einzelplan 60 ihr ein bisschen
ausgeblendet worden ist muss man aber
wobei allerdings auch die kollegen die
den eindruck erwecken als sei das
sozusagen schon klar wofür diese fünf
milliarden zur verfügung stehen dass es
nicht so den krisenprävention
würde ich mir jetzt auch wünschen wird
im bmz angesiedelt ich finde es gut und
richtig das ist ihr job dass die
ministerin darauf anspruch angemeldet
hat die außenministerin hatte vorhin
auch getan und aber auf der anderen
seite kann das auch sagen dass das
kabinett das geld schon noch anders
einsetzen werden die krise in die wir
gehen national und international kann
natürlich noch handeln ab war dann dass
wir jetzt noch nicht absehen können und
dafür ist eigentlich der einzelplan 60
da kollegen der union haben auch
herumgemäkelt wir sollten im haushalt
klarheit schaffen und dass man auflösen
dabei ist dieses instrument in der
großen koalition in ein krisen zu recht
genutzt worden weil dafür ist es da in
der flüchtlingskrise haben wir es
genutzt so eine reserve aufzubauen mit
wolfgang schäuble als finanzminister und
in der korona pandemie haben wir es auch
gemacht und es ist richtig und das ist
vernünftig so eine vorsorge zu haben und
darum kritisieren sind nicht etwas was
in wahrheit gut ist und bier
parlamentarier wir schon sagen ja für
die transparenz und hessen hat im
haushaltsausschuss die beschlüsse aber
eines ist auch klar
der regierung das was hier von vielen
gefordert wird dann müssen den rahmen da
muss noch mehr geschehen ich habe da im
einzelnen immer ganz viel sympathie
führen aber das wird natürlich ein stück
weiter eindruck erweckt als könnten wir
haushälter zaubern und einfach mehr
schulden machen als vorgesehen ist und
genau das könnte nicht mehr werden ein
haushaltsausschuss und das parlament
kann nicht eine höhere
nettokreditaufnahme sozusagen als in
regierung machen aber wir können sind
eine abstimmung wenn nämlich die
regierung wenn die regierung uns tanzen
die vorlage geliefert und darum es sind
noch spannende monate bis zum 10
november dass unsere bereinigungssitzung
und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen
dass wir in dieser zeit angesichts der
multiplen krisen auch noch weitere
vorschläge von unserer regierung kriegen
und dann werden wir sie als haushälter
zuverlässig im laufenden verfahren
umsetzen
das ist einfach so
was mir noch wichtig ist ist hier schon
sehr viel von der ernährungssituation
gesprochen worden und darum finde ich
dass ich meine ministerin svenja schulze
ja auch mal ausdrücklich loben darf
dafür deswegen die mich schon mai im mai
im rahmen der g7 präsidentschaft mit den
entwicklungsministerin und
entwicklungsministern der g7 staaten
zusammen das bündnis für globale
ernährung gegründet hat und dem ja auch
taten folgen und es ist ja auch kein
zufall dass der koalitionsausschuss am
letzten sonntag im rahmen des großen
pakets dieser eine milliarde noch für
die ernährungssicherheit
beschlossen hat das werden wir im
haushalt waren auch noch menschen weil
es nämlich noch in 22 der haushalt dass
es schließen muss und abschließend mehr
und wichtig ist mir auch dass die
beschaffung von getreide natürlich das
eine ist es ist aber auch so dass es
sich nur schwer zu beschaffen ist wegen
der kornkammer ukraine und in
russland sondern es ist auch so dass es
einfach immer teurer wird und darum kann
die weltgemeinschaft von dem zur
verfügung gestellten geld nicht mehr die
man beschaffen die eigentlich
erforderlich sind und darum stehen wir
sehr wahrscheinlich vor der größten
hungerkatastrophe der nachkriegszeit in
diesem jahr und dann müssen wir als
gesäten präsidentschaft eben auch unsere
internationalen verantwortung gerecht
werden und ich bin sicher dass es nicht
nur als svenja schulze und annalena
baerbock vorhinein gefordert haben
sondern dass die regierung insgesamt ein
hohes interesse daran haben wird und
haben muss dass unser renommee ein
starkes deutschland in der welt nicht
beschädigt wird und dass wir das was wir
mit dem mit dem paket am letzten
wochenende national auf den weg gebracht
haben was heute morgen in der runde die
große rolle gespielt hat was machen wie
auf nationaler ebene um der krise zu
begegnen
das bedeutet aber für so ein großes
starkes land wie deutschland auch dass
wir unsere internationalen verantwortung
gerecht werden müssen und gerecht werden
wollen und auch ich gehöre zu denjenigen
die sagen und lasse mir den
haushaltsansätzen schon so optimal
klappt da wäre ich jetzt eher skeptisch
aber ich würde schon sagen da muss uns
dann auch unsere regierung vorschläge zu
machen und ich bin sicher dass sie das
auch tun wird und in diesem sinne
ich kann jetzt alles andere was ich mir
eigentlich aufgeschrieben hatte nichts
sagen aber eins nicht mehr am herzen
gedanken hier auch oft zu recht gerne
und ich möchte mich jetzt mal bedanken
bei den über 23.000 mitarbeitern die für
und mit der gez weltweit für uns
arbeiten das werde nicht manchmal
vergessen was für ein großes starkes
netzwerk wir haben und übrigens auch
diese menschen schauen auf unser budget
weil die wissen vor ort wie dringend es
wirklich dabei zu bleiben und übrigens
von den über 23.000 über 7.600 ports
kräfte und vor diesem hintergrund denke
ich lassen sie uns all diesen die z
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern räume
geben wir in hoffnung dass sie ihre
arbeit im unvermindert der qualität
fortsetzen können vielen dank
bettina hagedorn die sie von ihrem
redemanuskript abgewichen ist aufgrund
der vor reden so wünscht man sich das ja
auch im parlament dass man aufeinander
eingeht pauli mir ist der nächste redner
konnte hier schon ein paar hände
schütteln weil er gestern 37 jahre alt
geworden ist
sie denn meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren der haushaltsentwurf für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist
enttäuschend er ist bitter zehn prozent
weniger für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
eineinviertel milliarden euro weniger
wenn man noch den ergänzungs haushalt
für den ukraine krieg berücksichtigt
dann sind es sogar 17 prozent weniger
mittel die dem bmz zur verfügung stehen
und das heißt in diesen zeiten machen
wir uns jetzt mal sagen was man deutlich
wie sies zeitenwende aller spd in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
bedeutet weniger geld für die
armutsbekämpfung weniger geld für die
pandemie bekämpfung und weniger geld für
die bekämpfung der fluchtursachen das
ist die politik der zeitenwende im
bereich der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
und man könnte meinen wenn man den
haushaltsentwurf sich anschaut dass die
globale lage entspannter geworden ist
als letztes oder vorletztes jahr das
gegenteil ist der fall pandemie ukraine
krieg ganz viele andere bewaffnete
konflikte die veränderung des klimas die
erderwärmung die zusätzlich
migrationsdruck erzeugt die
schlussfolgerung wir richtig zu sagen
das erfordert mehr deutsches engagement
aber diese bundesregierung diese ampel
sagt nein wir werden in zukunft weniger
machen aufgrund der globalen situation
und deswegen sagen sie fragen danke an
die ngo aus dank an die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter im bmz und in allen
organisationen der und der gz auch aber
bmz haben sie hoffentlich auch gemeint
die alle tatkräftig
diese arbeit leisten sie sagen danke und
1 dank verkürzen sie die mittel für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit das ist doch
ironie das ist doch ironie was sollen
sind jetzt ein organisationen denken die
diese debatte verfolgen sie finden
schöne worte aber nicht das geld nicht
das geld um sie entsprechend zu
unterstützen ja das ist nun mal so wie
diese regierung ist kein verlass
deswegen dank an alle organisationen sie
können auch cdu und csu zählen denn wir
haben übrigens jahr
gebraucht hätte
zwei wünsche nach zwischen fragen und
bemerkungen von fragen und von einem
wandertag möchten sie eine von beiden
bleibe oder keine zu lassen wenn ich
lasse sich lachse beigezogen beide ich
lasse beim mutig dann bitte beide
nacheinander als berater in havanna job
und dann sie zur antwort und hier gibts
pause
so stolz auf die historie der bmz
haushalte sind möchte ich immer
bestimmen
es gab ja eine schwarz gelbe regierung
von 292 13 da waren 6,07 milliarden
brauchen 2010 und 2013 dann ist es 6,0
zu
in der nächsten ko wir dann in unserem
koalitionsvertrag dafür gekämpft dass es
eben eine parallele anhebung von mitteln
für den verteidigungsetat in bmc täter
gibt es war ein schwerer kampf aber wir
haben es geschafft und daraufhin wurden
dann unter wolfgang schäuble die
etatmittel erhöht bis 2017 auf 85
milliarden euro immerhin von 6 auf 8,5
und dann kann die nächste große
koalition und olaf scholz wurde
finanzminister und die mitte gestiegen
gesteigert worden von 805 auf über zwölf
milliarden euro und in den beiden jahren
die beiden letzten jahren durch die
korona pandemien durch die sondermitteln
die wir dafür aus gehabt habe eben sogar
noch über noch mehr so wie können sie
jetzt apple mit wir haben vergleichen
und wie können sie sich einen hinstellen
und angesichts dieser zahlen für die sie
die verantwortung trage
können sie eigentlich sagen
dass sich die andrews auf sie verlassen
können und nicht auf dieser regierung
vielen dank goalie wird für die
möglichkeit eine frage zu stellen ich
würde ja an manchen stellen ihnen in der
sache durchaus zustimmen haben seine
rede gehört und in zwischenrufen aus
ihrer fraktion hat entnommen dass dieses
konzept selbstbewusste abgeordneter das
oppositionszeiten kennt aber in der
regierung jetzt selbst nicht angewandt
haben also dass hier
auch einen regierungsentwurf in teilen
kritisieren weil wir haben eine
verfassung scheint für sie eine neue
situation zu sein aber gewöhnt sich dran
dass wir noch häufiger passiert meine
frage ist weil ich im letzten haushalt
zu fragen mich noch gut erinnern kann
dass auch in dem bereich auch bei grödig
krokodilstränen sehr sehr groß war und
sich über alle einzelpläne in der
haushaltsberatung die mehr anmeldungen
nur so gehäuft haben ob du freak hat
eine lange liste von dingen und was
alles noch drauf kommen sollte und
gleichzeitig außer bei der teams dabei
ist in jeder rede aus ihrer fraktion die
schuldenbremse und die schlimme
expansive ausgabenpolitik dieser ampel
angesprochen worden mein rat an zieht
gibt es grund zu haben
diese haushaltswoche in ihrer fassung
mit etwas weniger inneren widersprüchen
abgeschlossen wird
[Applaus]
zunächst einmal vor kollegen danke für
diese zwischenfrage denn es ist wichtig
noch mal tatsächlich auf die fakten
hinzuweisen denn es war gerd müller als
war cdu und csu zu verdanken dass die
der haushaltstitel immer weiter
angestiegen es so war es und sie haben
dieselbe ich will mal sagen wir haben
gesagt die letzte regierung die letzte
koalition hinter kroko haben wir es
geschafft tatsächlich wir haben es aber
nicht wegen olaf scholz geschafft
sondern weil der schüler sich
durchgesetzt wonach er hat doch gekämpft
ich kann ihnen gerne nochmal die artikel
ins büro zu kommen lassen wo wir wieder
öffentlich gesagt hat das ist so wenig
geld für die entwicklungshilfe und er
hat es am ende geschafft dass das
welternährungsprogramm
ausreichend ausgestattet ist und das ist
der unterschied der letzten regierung zu
dieser regierung frau schulze sie kürzen
bei der bekämpfung der armut wir haben
immer das ziel verfolgt dass eine welt
ohne hunger
glücklich ist und daran halten wir fest
und werden wir wieder diese boden
designer bundesregierung dieser nicht
einer bundesregierung der
bundesregierung führen dann werden wir
das auch wieder umsetzen und jetzt zu
der frage der inneren widersprüche ich
will ihnen sagen die er kenne ich auch
und vor allem bei ihnen denn ja wenn man
sich jetzt anschaut wie heute hier die
redebeiträge ausgefallen sind kann die
ministerin bei ihrem entwurf nur bei dem
bezüglich der kürzung nur auf fdp und
afd 10 sonst haben sie alle abgelehnt
sie haben das ja auch alles abgelehnt
ist schon ziemlich mitterrand dach für
die bundesregierung hier aber es wird
nicht so kommen das weiß ich und das
sehe ich auch schon wie sie blicken am
ende werden sie natürlich alles tun was
die bundesregierung will und sie werden
am ende diesem haushalt zustimmen so
wird es sein so kennen wir das das sind
die neuen grünen in der bundesregierung
meine meine
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
dann wird hier viel gesprochen von
feministischer außenpolitik und
entwicklungspolitik jeder der sich
auskennt in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit weiß und es
ist ja auch schon ein richtiger weise
gesagt worden dass frauen eben die
gruppe sind die am meisten leiden und
leiden unter bewaffneten konflikten
flucht migration armut und vieles mehr
deswegen ist es ein richtiger ansatz
besonders frauen auch besonders junge
frauen zu unterstützen und solche
programme aber das gegenteil tut die
bundesregierung sie kürzt nicht nur
schon 2022 die mikrofone förderung von
mikrokrediten irgendwo zwischen 80 und
96 prozent derjenigen die davon
profitieren sind frauen sondern eben
jetzt auch es ist richtiger weise
kritisiert worden das programm united
nations woman ein sinnvolles programm
mit vielen mit viel engagement für den
schutz von frauen weltweit für mehr
gleichberechtigung und gleichstellung
und übrigens mit dem aktionstag world
wir kennen ihn alle den wir unterstützen
sie kürzen diese mittel feministische
außenpolitik bedeutet aber wenn man sich
den haushalt anschaut mehr geld mehr
geld mehr geld für die pr der ministerin
dass steigt an woanders werden frauen
programm gekürzt aber die pr abteilung
der ministerin bekommt mehr geld von
dieser feministischen außenpolitik der
ampel profitiert nur eine frau auf
dieser welt und das ist die
bundesministerin nicht
meine sehr verehrten mannes erfährt
damen und herren felix magath hat noch
mal was angesprochen zu der frage naja
wie glaubwürdig ist das alles eigentlich
zu beginn der legislaturperiode haben
mit ihren einlassungen zur
entwicklungspolitik gut gefallen genauso
wie deborah döring im ausschuss vieles
richtige angesprochen hat sie haben den
richtigen kompass bewiesen aber am ende
ja aber am ende werden sie diesem
haushalt ich habe es gerade schon gesagt
zustimmen das versteht kein mensch warum
sie diese diese geringere ausstattung
unterstützen in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die
wissenschaft kennt dafür hatten sie
brauchen gar nicht zugucken die
wissenschaft kennt dafür nur einen
ausdruck das ist das sogenannte stop das
ist das sogenannte stockholm-syndrom das
opfer einer entführung hier die grünen
solidarisieren sich mit dem täter der
spd weil die steht noch viel bitterer
noch viel bitterer wer als sich darauf
einzulassen jetzt einfach mitzumachen
der stockholm syndrom sagt die sagt die
wissenschaft zudem wie sich die grünen
in der entwicklungspolitik an da heißt
es wenn sie wirklich wieder vernünftige
und besser ausgestattete
entwicklungspolitik machen wollen dann
können sie in diesem haus langfristig
nur auf cdu und csu setzen dankeschön
paul signac hat hier unter anderem die
un kampagne the world angesprochen das
ist eine kampagne die ab dem 25 november
jedes jahr stattfindet und in der
weltweit gebäude in orangener farbe
angestrahlt werden um ein sichtbares
zeichen gegen gewalt an frauen zu setzen
präsidentin liebe ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die eins zu
eins regel wurde von uns grünen
vorgeschlagen und erkämpft und ich bin
sehr glücklich dass wir uns im
koalitionsvertrag darauf geeinigt haben
und wir werden auch daran festhalten
ich finde es immer sehr witzig wenn von
der cdu irgendwas über feminismus kommt
von einer partei damit die noch nicht
mal eine frauenquote hat da können sie
ja noch nachbessern und als
klimaaktivisten weil sie auch zum
klimaschutz angesprochen haben ich meine
ich habe ja er lebt milch wie sie
agieren gegenüber menschen die
klimaschutz in ihrer region erbringen
wollen wie gewalttätig sie auch da
vorgegangen sind deswegen finde ich es
immer ein wenig absurd wenn ihr über
klimaschutz redet und ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen hättet ihr auf uns gehört
dann wären wir jetzt nicht in der
situation in der wir uns befinden 12
grad globale erhitzung und deswegen habe
ich jetzt zum eigentlichen thema
klima finanzen
mitte für inter werd mir zu vielleicht
lernt ihr noch etwas mitte für
internationale maßnahmen gegen die
klimakrise und mittel für den aufbau von
klima resilienz entscheidend schon jetzt
über das überleben von vielen menschen
und wer die existenz ganzer regionen
dass die klimakrise bereits grausame
realität ist sehen wir in pakistan das
land es aktuell zu einem drittel
überflutet mehr als 30 millionen
menschen sind betroffen mehr als
1300 menschen sind gestorben und es
werden noch mehr menschen sterben wenn
krankheiten sich nun ausbreiten und weil
die ernte zerstört worden ist
an dieser stelle wäre es vermutlich
normal schöne worte der anteilnahme zu
finden aber ich bring das nicht richtig
übers herz den ehrlich schöne worte
fühlen sich gerade falsch an wenn wir es
noch nicht geschafft haben unsere
internationale vereinbarungen im bereich
internationaler klima klima gelder dem
nachzukommen und deswegen werden wir
weiter dann arbeiten unserer
verantwortung nachkommen auf der
nächsten weltklimakonferenz in ägypten
wird der diskurs über los und der messe
über verlust und schäden der klimakrise
über den erfolg der konferenz bestimmen
die flutkatastrophe aktuell in pakistan
verdeutlicht die notwendigkeit einer
einsetzung der los und der mensch
passivität mit der bereitstellung von
geldern damit länder damit regionen die
solche wetter extreme erleben direkt auf
hohe finanzen zugreifen können das klima
gerechtigkeit und dafür werden wir uns
auch aus dem bundestag heraus ein setzen
[Applaus]
die 2015 in paris versprochenen 100
milliarden an thema finanzen auch daran
werden wir arbeiten aktuell kann ich
erst 4,3 milliarden im bundeshaushalt
finden da wird es sehr wichtig sein das
hat auch das finanzministerium die
gelder erhöht denn alleine durch auch
durch umschichtung werden wir die auf
höchste nicht erbringen können also auch
hier werden wir einige milliarden wir
benötigen und auch dafür streiten und
auch bei der schuldenbremse da muss ich
sagen die schuldenbremse darf kein
argument sein wenn es um klima finanzen
geht denn jeder cent den wir jetzt für
maßnahmen gegen die klimakrise erbringen
der rettet leben und da wird auch
ökosysteme retten uns vor wetterextrem
bewahren aber wir erleben ja gerade
nicht nur die klimakrise sondern auch
die biodiversitäts krise global erleben
wir ein artensterben leiser als eine
sturmflut aber genauso tödlich weltweit
geraten ökosysteme unter massiven druck
auch und besonders wegen der klimakrise
deswegen fordern wir
eine verdoppelung der internationalen
mittel für biodiversitätsschutz
mindestens zwei milliarden müssen wir
zur verfügung stellen daran werden wir
weiter arbeiten und ich will noch einen
letzten satz sagen wir sind angetreten
um die klima und biodiversität krise
ernst zu nehmen das muss sich jetzt auch
im bundeshaushalt niederschlagen und da
freue ich mich mit mich mit euch wieder
allen zusammenzuarbeiten vielen dank
sagt kathrin henneberger von bündnis 90
die grünen hier im deutschen bundestag
markus maier spricht als nächstes er ist
der sprecher für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung der afg
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die presse überschlägt sich becker am
limit traditions- schuhhändler görtz ist
insolvent us bank jp morgan bereitet
sich auf blackout in deutschland vor
gaspreis explosion bringt tausende jobs
in gefahr was macht diese regierung
diese regierung schickt erneut hunderte
millionen euro in die ukraine diese
regierung bezahlt nachdem bereits zehn
milliarden euro zugesagt worden sind
erneut millionen für klimaprojekte in
indien und diese regierung
zweckentfremdet im rahmen des
entlastungs paketes sogenannte
haushaltsreste und verteilt eine
milliarde euro ins ausland für die
eigenen bürger hingegen da gibt es
energiespartipps und verachtung für die
tägliche frische sorgt jetzt der
waschlappen auf anraten von herr
kretschmann
wirtschaftsprofil habeck gerät bei
maischberger zu insolvenzverschleppung
denn zitat die leute gehen nicht pleite
die arbeiten einfach nur nicht mehr und
frau baerbock bekundet ganz offen
ukrainische interessen über die der
deutschen bürger zu stellen meine damen
und herren diese regierung bringt
wirklich alles mit was man zum dritt
welt land braucht sie entwickeln
deutschland von einer industrienationen
hin zu einem zusammen
ja wir weiter steuergeld für gender
sensible männerarbeit
klimaneutrale koch technologie oder led
lampen in marokkanischen moscheen
bezahlt der ist nicht die
bundesregierung der deutschen sie sind
die bundesregierung der ukraine sie sind
die bundesregierung des auslands
der bolide dort trifft man hat das wort
für die fdp tritt
[Applaus]
ja nach dieser rede von herrn frohnmeyer
glauben braucht man nicht viel dazu
sagen das ist wie immer schäbiges nicht
versuchen die ärmsten der welt
auszuspielen und das ist einfach
unanständig
wir haben gesehen in deutschland und das
hat auch zur krise geführt dass er große
abhängigkeiten hatten zu russland aber
wir haben sie auch zu china und unsere
neue strategie muss einfach sein
deutschland braucht viele freunde und da
kommt die entwicklungszusammenarbeit ins
spiel weil wir haben uns über
entwicklungszusammenarbeit einen sehr
guten ruf in dieser welt erworben und es
ist die große politische tugend
verlässlich zu sein
verlässlichkeit machen wir auch weil wir
unseren internationalen verpflichtungen
nachkommen die jetzt auch im haushalt
drin sind herr müller hat sehr hohe
internationale verpflichtungen
eingegangen aber wir versuchen das jetzt
auch wirklich in taten umzusetzen
erklärt die pmz anteile im haushalt 22
waren genau 204 9 prozent und raten sie
mal wie es in diesem jahr sind auch 24 9
prozent also das heißt wir haben nur
einen gesamthaushalt der schrumpft aber
der anteil der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist der
gleiche soviel zum prozent rechnen bei
der cdu auch die oda-quote mit 0,7 er
und das ist glaube ich ein gutes zeichen
weil wir damit zeigen dass wir
international unseren verpflichtungen
nachkommen und unseren beitrag dazu
geben dass die welt besser wird aber wir
haben reserven und darüber steht auf die
müssen wir uns konzentrieren bei
schrumpfenden haushaltsmitteln das ist
zum einmal die bürokratie abbauen wir
haben bei gez kfw noch hohe
bürokratiekosten und ich glaube wir
können da ein hohes wirkungspotenzial
entfalten es gibt nur ein beispiel
vergabe grenzen
zweitens wir müssen systeme statt
projekte installieren systeme die aus
sich selbst heraus wachsen und selbst
private gelder auch anziehen nur ein
beispiel
start up center dies integriert worden
sind auch mit deutscher
entwicklungszusammenarbeit haben sich
bewährt haben eine große finanzmittel
akquiriert und ganz wichtig wir brauchen
einen länder datenbank damit alle
ministerien ihre ausgaben und
aktivitäten hier eintragen und wir sie
wieder fitten und wird doppler vermeiden
und es ist auch klar alle öffentliche
gelder werden nicht reichen so lange wir
nicht privates kapital mobilisieren für
die entwicklung und das heißt
investitionen mobilisieren für die
entwicklungsländer das ist die große
erleichterung die auf dauer dann auch
wirkt und wir empfehlen einen
wirtschaftsbeauftragten für afrika im
kanzleramt zu etablieren ich glaube das
ist ein signal dass wir auch in der geo
strategie bräuchten sie sehen
ich habe jetzt mehrere maßnahmen
aufgeführt die in ihrer wirkung in ihrem
wirkungspotenzial mehreren milliarden
gleich stehen dennoch die hungerkrise
lässt nicht nach und 23 werden wir
dasselbe nochmal erleben mal in der
ukraine kein dünger produziert wird weil
dort kein saatgut produziert wird die
krise ist jetzt abgemildert wird ist ein
bisschen schwächer geworden und die
ukraine lieferungen laufen und ich bin
der koalition sehr dankbar dass sie
nochmal eine milliarde zur verfügung
gestellt hat um die aktuelle krise zu
bekämpfen
herr kollege
ich sehe die uhr blinken gut und ich
plädiere dafür dass wir auch aus den im
kommenden haushalt vorhandenen
ergänzungsmittel von fünf milliarden
einen großen teil für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
reservieren das heißt wir können die
schuldenbremse einhalten auf der einen
seite blinkt und haben genügend mittel
auf der anderen seite um den hunger zu
bekämpfen herzlichen dank
das war die rede von christoph hoffmann
von der fdp-fraktion
hier zum einzelplan 23 entwicklung wir
haben es gehört hier in der debatte es
gab viel kritik daran dass dieser
einzelplan vorsieht dass das ministerium
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung etwa zehn prozent weniger
2023 zur verfügung haben soll als in
diesem jahr allerdings ist das hier der
etat de zum ersten mal diskutiert wird
das heißt dieser einzelplan geht jetzt
in den haushaltsausschuss steht dort
noch einmal zur debatte und dann werden
wir wahrscheinlich bei der zweiten und
dritten lesung uns mit anderen zahlen
nochmal beschäftigen